perhaps one of the most significant
things about our Vanderbilt expose is
that it has gotten a significant amount
of media coverage actually of course you
know usually the media prefers to Simply
ignore these sorts of inconvenient
things it's certainly been the case for
anything I've been involved in up until
now still to this day for example my
film what is a woman has not been
reviewed by a single mainstream media
publication but the Vanderbilt situation
has garnered attention from Outlets that
normally prefer to use the journalistic
strategy of closing your eyes covering
your ears and humming loudly to yourself
until the scary story goes away they
haven't quite done that here and that's
not because they've had a change of
heart mind you okay I'm not giving them
credit or accusing them of engaging in
Acts of actual journalism it's only
because they realize that the backlash
against the trans agenda and especially
against the transiting of kids
is gaining steam despite their best
efforts at deflection and they're soon
going to be in a position where they've
lost all control over it so they have no
choice but to engage now they're trying
to get out in front of it and shape the
narrative and the conversation in a way
that's convenient for them
now we have in other words dragged the
media Kicking and Screaming into a
conversation that it desperately does
not want to have
now as far as that goes there are two
articles uh both published yesterday one
in a national outlet and one in a local
that I think perfectly capture the
leftist media's approach to the
Vanderbilt Scandal and to this topic
overall in general and taken together
they show that the left is they're
backed into a corner here they're
intellectually out of ammo and firing
blanks it's no wonder they'd rather just
ignore all of this if they could so the
vehicle is from a publication called
inside higher education the headline is
attack on Vanderbilt Clinic has Ripple
effects
it continues last Tuesday Matt Walsh a
conservative pundit and columnist for
the right wing right-wing website the
daily wire released what he called a
quote investigation into Vanderbilt's
clinic for transgender Health to his
over 1 million Twitter followers among
other things he asserted that vumc
established the clinic in 2018 because
gender affirming surgeries were quote
money makers that the center threatened
consequences for staff who declined to
provide gender affirming care and that
it tried to enforce compliance from
parents who might be hesitant to consent
to care for their minor children
Snippets of video are presented as
evidence for these claims
yes what I called an investigation well
I called it that because we
investigated Vanderbilt and we found out
certain things and then we presented
those things to the public I I do call
that an investigation because that's
what the word means
but the few lines I just read
represent
the full extent of this article's
summary of the findings of my
investigation from there it launches
into a lengthy editorial disguised as an
objective news report slamming me for
quote intimidating doctors and quote
threatening access to life-saving care
and it of course makes the totally
unsubstantiated claim that quote gender
affirming care for minors is medically
necessary and as proof for this claim
they cite the leftist activist group The
the Trevor Project
okay they cite the Trevor Project as
evidence which I mean you might as well
cite Trevor Noah I don't know it's it's
there's no credibility whatsoever this
is an activist group and but they're
often cited as uh sources for the claims
that the left makes on this subject the
article never mentions the fact that
Vanderbilt performs irreversible gender
surgeries on minors gives irreversible
hormone drugs to kids as young as 13
doesn't even mention that
and here's the most revealing thing
though
they could not find a single health care
provider at Vanderbilt who would defend
this practice on the record I mean
defend it to a publication that's
totally on their side they were trying
to find someone who would just say the
things that they want they were trying
to find a medical professional who would
say the things that they want them to
say
um and they couldn't do that in fact
they had trouble finding any doctors
anywhere who would actually publicly
defend the practice of irreversibly
mutilating and drugging kids
but they say that of course is my fault
too
reading again from the article says
whatever the ultimate goals of the
commentators and lawmakers scrutinizing
trans health clinics the immediate
impact of their work has been to
intimidate Professionals in the field
into Silence of the eight specialists in
transgender Health contacted by inside
higher ed for this article only two
agreed to speak on the record all said
they fervently believe in their work but
that the risks of openly defending their
practice have become too great to make
speaking out to defend it worth the
dangers of harassment
right
so they refuse to defend their own
medical practices on the record because
they're intimidated
which is actually true
but they're intimidated uh in the same
way that cockroaches are intimidated
when you turn on the light they they are
intimidated because they prefer to
operate in darkness when no one is
looking they are intimidated by the
truth not by me not by threats they're
intimidated by the truth
they know they're being exposed
now they did find one person who would
um speak on the record though well two
they say and one is none other than
Michelle forsier who's the pediatrician
who appeared in what is a woman and who
famously if you watch that film you know
she would she was the one who would not
affirm that only female chickens lay
eggs she wouldn't affirm that she also
threatened to walk out of the room when
I asked her about the chemical
castration drugs that she prescribes to
children now forsier's defense of
Vanderbilt's greed and profit-driven
Medical Care is that essentially
everyone does it she says quote anybody
who works in a hospital setting knows
that there are budgets there are looks
at costs and expenditures and more
resources go to programs that bring in
more money that's the economics of
Health Care any Cardiovascular Center
for instance looks at their surgical
income versus outpatient and surgery is
always going to make more money than
outpatient services none of that should
be shocking news
hmm
more resources go to programs that bring
in more money
these people just keep exposing
themselves and and you can tell why most
of them prefer to hide and stay silent
because every time they open their mouth
they accidentally say things that uh
proves exactly the point we're trying to
prove
and then the article has this this is my
favorite part it says forsier is
personally familiar with Walsh's brand
of misinformation and targeted
harassment
few years back she agreed to be
interviewed for his documentary what is
a woman whose Central thesis is that
transgender identity is a harmful and
unscientific fad forsier said she agreed
to the interview because she's
passionate about the issue and committed
advocate for transgender youth health
care but that she was greeted with
obstinacy and bad faith questions she's
been wary of doing any media interviews
including with inside higher ed ever
since
quote when you're targeted in terms of
hate crimes and victimization you're
careful where you go she said you're
careful who you talk to
now anyone can watch the film and see
that all of the obsidency and bad faith
was coming from the other side of the
issue but I am interested to find out
that she apparently considers
the interview that we did did to be a
hate crime
the interview was a hate crime is
apparently what you're saying
and we've gotten many
we haven't gotten many Critic reviews of
the film but I think that's probably the
only review you need maybe we put that
on the on the movie poster
now meanwhile on the local side a
leftist rag called the Nashville Scene
published an article from a woman named
Betsy Phillips and we'll have more on
Betsy Phillips in just a moment the
article is titled we are lucky as a
community to have a pediatric
transgender Clinic we have a place where
kids who are dealing with huge decisions
with far-reaching implications can speak
with medical professionals
that's how it starts and it only gets
dumber from there Phillips claims that
kids who are dealing with huge decisions
should consult with the very people who
have an enormous Financial stake
in making sure that they transition as
early as possible
this is exactly why the profitability
point profitability point is so
important
because you don't have to be the most
observant person in the world to notice
that there's a conflict of interest here
okay you just need to have a moderately
functioning brain which is a bar too
high for Betsy Phillips to get over
apparently she continues
I want to write about the rights attack
on transgender kids and the people who
provide them medical assistance
but I have to be honest with you I'm
depressed about it it feels like for a
vast swath of us words have no meaning
so it doesn't matter which words I
arrange or how it's not going to matter
doctors and therapists are trying to
help trans kids are still going to be
called groomers and mutilators parents
who live every day with their distressed
kids and who are trying to find some way
for them to be in the world and Thrive
are called abusers it's not true and we
all could take the time to refute it but
the whole point of them doing this kind
of thing is to cause us to waste our
time doing so
well not the whole point I'm sure
right-wing activists and media
personalities like Matt Walsh and Tucker
Carlson uh their intention is to put
people in danger
so to be clear the side that considers
it a hate crime when you ask them to
define words
is now accusing us of treating words
like they have no meaning and aside that
that pushes millions of kids into brutal
surgeries that will destroy their bodies
forever is accusing us of putting people
in danger
continuing there there are some gems
like this it says it's okay to initially
be confused by the idea of transgender
people on the one hand once you um know
to to look for trans gender people you
see them throughout history
actually there is no historical
precedent at all for men who claim
actually literally to be women and vice
versa there has never been a society in
history that believes men can give birth
that's never existed until now but it's
not surprising to hear Betsy make a
historically illiterate claim like this
when you consider that this is also the
person who wrote The Following in the
same article now in response to our
objections to performing irreversible
surgeries on kids Betsy says this
this should go without saying but we let
kids make permanent life-altering
decisions that hurt them all the time
it's called football if you have Top
surgery and later regret it that's a
hell of a lot easier to repair than a
brain riddled with CTE
we see what happens to people with CTE
the memory loss the suicides the
violence against family members and we
all know it's caused by bashing your
head and how many of us spend our
weekends watching kids bash their heads
well what else do you need to know about
these people
she's saying body bodily mutilation is
akin to football
ignoring the fact that um well you have
to ignore a lot of facts to make this
argument but one of them is that she's
annoying is that
traumatic injury in football
is not the point of the sport
okay that's what happens when the sport
goes wrong
whereas traumatic permanent injury to a
child through quote gender affirming
drugs and surgery is the whole point and
it's the only possible outcome
so the more accurate analogy is not to
football where injuries are a byproduct
a side effect
really the analogy would be simply to
just walking up to a kid and whacking
him in the head with a baseball bat
and then defending Yourself by claiming
that he wanted you to do it
and aside from all that here's here's
the the even bigger point
people like Betsy pretty clear from what
she said there
they don't want kids to play football
for exactly this reason
that it might result in permanent injury
in fact there are a lot of people these
days that say I don't want my kid
involved in football
why because it's going to hurt them and
uh and also because they are taking
risks that they don't fully understand
at this age
that seems to be Betsy's position
and yet she passionately advocates for
intentional permanent injuries to be
inflicted on kids in the name of gender
affirmation
these people cannot offer any argument
that doesn't defeat their own point
which is why they usually prefer to stay
silent
Betsy though did not stay silent and
there's a reason for that it isn't
disclosed anywhere in the article but
through a little bit of research
investigation you might say I discovered
that Betsy Works in marketing for
Vanderbilt's publishing imprint
so this is what the leftist media is
reduced to printing PR releases written
by Vanderbilt marketing execs and
pretending that it's an editorial from a
third party
well what else are they going to do
I mean they would publish full
compelling evidence-based defenses from
actual medical professionals but uh but
they can't because those people are all
in hiding because they're scared of me
and I believe that partially
I mean I believe that they're scared
but they're scared not because we're
jeopardizing their physical safety we
aren't
but because we're coming for their
bottom line
they're Prophets
and that we are and that'll do it for us
for this portion of the show as we move
over to the members block hope to see
you there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]